alright let's see we can find the limit
of 1 over square root of 2 sine of theta
over cosine of 2 theta as theta
approaches negative PI over 4 and like
always try to give it a shot before we
go through it together
well one take on it is well let's just
let's just say that this is going to be
the same thing as the limit as theta
approaches negative PI over 4 of 1 plus
square root of 2 sine theta over the
limit as theta approaches negative PI
over 4 make sure we can see that
negative there of cosine of 2 theta and
both of these expressions are if these
were function definitions or if we were
to graph y equals 1 plus square root of
sine square root of 2 times sine theta
or y equals cosine of 2 theta we would
get continuous functions especially at
theta is equal to negative PI over 4 so
we could just substitute in and say well
this is going to be equal to this
expression evaluated it negative PI over
4 so 1 plus square root of 2 times sine
of negative PI over 4 over cosine of 2
times negative PI over 4 now negative PI
over 4 sine of negative PI over 4 is
going to be negative square root of 2
over 2 so this is negative square root
of 2 over 2 we're assuming this is in
radians if we're thinking degrees this
would be a negative 45 degree angle so
this is one of the one of the the trig
values that it's good to know and so if
you have if you had one so see well X to
me just rewrite it so this is going to
be equal to one plus square root of two
times that is going to be negative two
over two so this is going to be minus
one that's the numerator over here all
of this stuff simplifies to negative one
over this is going to be cosine of
negative PI over two all right this is
negative PI over two
sine of negative PI over 2 if you
thought it agrees that's going to be
negative 90 degrees well cosine of that
is just going to be is zero so what we
end up with is equal to zero over zero
and as we've talked about before if we
had something non zero divided by zero
we'd say okay that's undefined we might
as well give up but we have this
indeterminate form it does not mean that
the limit does not exist it's usually a
clue that we should use some tools in
our toolkit one of which is to do some
manipulation here to get an expression
that maybe is defined at theta is equal
to or it is does not it is not an
indeterminate form at theta is equal to
negative PI over 4 and we'll see other
tools in our toolkit in the future so
let me algebraically manipulate this a
little bit so if I have one plus the
square root of two sine theta over
cosine two theta as you can imagine the
things that might be useful here are our
trig identities and in particular cosine
of two theta seems interesting let me
write some trig identities involving
cosine of two theta I'll write it over
here
so we know that cosine of two theta is
equal to cosine squared of theta minus
sine squared of theta which is equal to
one minus two sine squared of theta
which is equal to two cosine squared
theta minus one and you can go from this
one to this one to this one just using
the Pythagorean identity and we proved
that in earlier videos and intr Gotama
tree on Khan Academy now do any of these
look useful well all of these three are
going to be differences of squares so we
can factor them in interesting ways and
remember our goal in the end of the day
is maybe cancel things out that are
making us get this zero over zero and if
I could factor this into something that
involves a 1 plus square root of 2 sine
theta that I'm going to be in business
and it looks like it looks like this
right over here that can be factored as
1 plus square root of 2 sine theta
times 1 minus square root of 2 sine
theta so let me use this cosine of 2
theta is the same thing cosine of 2
theta is the same thing as 1 minus 2
sine squared theta which is just a
difference of squares we can rewrite
that as this is a squared minus B
squared this is a plus B times a minus B
so I can just replace this with 1 plus
the square root of 2 sine theta times 1
minus square root of 2 sine theta and
now we have some nice canceling or
potential canceling that can occur so we
could say that cancels with that and we
could say that that is going to be equal
let me do this in a new color this is
going to be equal to the numerator we
just have 1 in the denominator we just
start left with 1 minus square root of 2
sine theta and if we want these
expressions to truly be equal we would
have to have them to have the same if
you view them as function definitions is
having the same domain so this one right
over here this one we already saw is not
defined at theta is equal to negative PI
over 4 and so this one
in order for these to be equivalent we
have to say that this one is also not
and actually other places but let's just
let's just say theta does not does not
equal negative negative PI over 4 and we
could think about all of this happening
in some type of an open interval around
negative PI over 4 if we wanted to get
very precise but if we for for this
particular case well let's just say all
everything we're doing is in the open
interval so in an open interval in open
interval between theta or say negative 1
and 1 and I think that covers it because
if we have PI if we have PI over 4 that
is not going to get us the 0 over 0 form
and PI over 4 would make this
denominator equal to 0 but it also makes
let's see
over for also we'll make this
denominator equal to zero because we
would get one minus one so I think I
think we're good if we're just assuming
or restricting to this open interval and
that's okay because we're taking the
limit as it approaches something within
this open interval and I'm being extra
precise because I'm trying to explain it
to you and it's important to be precise
but obviously if you're working this out
on a test or notebook you wouldn't be
taking putting at or taking as much
trouble to put you putting all of these
caveats in so what we've now realized is
that okay this expression actually let's
think about this let's think about the
limit the limit as theta approaches
negative PI over 4 of this thing without
the restriction of 1 over 1 minus square
root of 2 sine of theta if we're dealing
with this over you know in this open
interval we achieve in your disregarding
that theta this data or this expression
is continuous at it is defined and it is
continuous at theta is equal to negative
PI over 4 so this is just going to be
equal to 1 over 1 minus the square root
of 2 times sine of negative PI over 4
sine of negative PI over 4 sine of
negative PI over 4 we've already seen is
negative square root of 2 over 2 and so
this is going to be equal to 1 over 1
minus square root of 2 times the
negative square root of 2 over 2 so
negative negative you get a positive
square root of 2 times square root of 2
is 2 over 2 is going to be 1 so this is
going to be equal to 1/2 and so I want
to be very clear this expression is not
the same thing as this expression they
are the same thing at all values of
theta is especially if we're dealing in
this open interval except at theta
equals negative PI over 4 this one is
not defined and this one is defined but
as we've seen multiple times before if
we find a function that is equal to our
original or an expression that's equal
equal to our original expression and all
values of theta except except
whether the original one was not defined
at a certain point but this new one is
defined and is continuous there well
then these two limits are going to be
equal so if this limit is 1/2 then this
limit is going to be 1/2 and I've said
this in previous videos it might be very
tempting so yeah well I'm just going to
algebraically simplify this in some way
to get this and I'm not going to worry
about too much about these constraints
and then I'm just going to substitute
negative PI over 4 and you will get this
answer which is the correct answer but
it's really important to recognize that
this expression and this expression are
not the same thing and what allows you
to do this is is the truth that if you
have two functions if you have F and G
two functions equal let me write it this
way equal equal for all X except for all
alright let me just write this way for
all X except for a then the limit then
and let me write it this way equal for
all for all except for all X except a
and F continuous continuous at a then
then the limit of f of X as X approaches
a is going to be equal to the limit of G
of X as X approaches a and I said this
in multiple videos and that's what we
are doing right here but just so you can
make sure you you got it right the
answer here is 1/2